did any of you throw your rank on the
table and say hey it's a bad idea to
evacuate bagram airfield the strategic
air barriers before we evacuate everyone
did anyone do that and when you didn't
think to do that did anyone raise their
hand and say we completely messed this
up potentially all those people did die
in vain if we don't have senior leaders
that own up and
raise their hand and say
we did not do this well in the end i
demand accountability and we all felt
that way but that lieutenant colonel is
paying a price that is lieutenant
colonel stu schiller back in august
criticizing the military ranks for their
botched withdrawal from afghanistan if
you don't mind me saying they
embarrassed the country he was relieved
of his military duties for speaking the
truth after that video was posted and
the military ranks were on a war path to
silence him ever since but schiller
continued to talk and now earlier this
week schiller was arrested for violating
the military's gag order which prevents
him from publicly criticizing the
pentagon stu sheller is a father of
three a husband and son and he's locked
away in the military break for
criticizing the obvious and now his
family is not allowed to see him but
they're not standing down kathy and stu
are standing up with us and they are the
parents of lieutenant colonel and they
join us right now so uh upset that you
have to go through this so glad you were
fighting stu let's start with you what
could you tell me about how your son is
today and the condition of his case
well we haven't seen him or talked to
him since monday morning when he asked
us to call his attorney and he asked us
to tell everyone this story so we've
been on
we've been blitzing uh to tell the story
to americans for the last five days and
americans have responded so his case
today he went to a hearing yesterday
we thought charges would be brought they
dropped a 60 640 page document on his
legal team with less than 24 hours
but charges were not filed yesterday
even though he still remains in jail
they haven't really technically told him
why
i would like to give special thanks to
representative louis
goldman goldberg from texas gomer from
texas who
stepped up
traveled to camp lejeune and agreed to
try to
have discussions between the marine
corps and stewart's legal team
they left yesterday and agreed that
they're going to work all weekend on a
possible positive
separation honorable discharge right
full va benefits but we found out today
from louis gohmert on
the hannity radio show that
they
have kind of changed their disposition
in the marine corps
they're digging in and they'd like to
burn
our son lieutenant colonel sheller we
have been told to prepare that it could
be a long prison term i want to
thank americans
you have
found your voice you have stood up right
you have contacted your congress people
and they are writing and they are
putting pressure on the marine corps the
pentagon and we appreciate that because
this is
not a particular steward although
it's although he's our son and and it is
about stewart it's about america we need
to take america back so we're telling
people to we're telling them to pray and
go to pipeline and go to
piperfoundation.org
we've already raised 1.8 million the
average donation 74 that shows you how
many americans are involved in this
kathy to you uh your son has fought with
valve for 17 years he's had five
deployments he's got a bronze star
accommodation for valor this is the type
of uh somebody we should be propping up
not putting in the brig
so what is your message to the rest of
the country
my son is an exemplary marine and he has
been for 17 years
he spoke out he knew he should not have
but he was torn between
ending the war as poorly as it was
horrible versus keeping it to himself he
knew that everyone else felt the same
way
he thought if he took the lead others
would stand up and call for
accountability they did not right so he
is taking the full brunt himself he knew
what he was doing i think he thought he
would be risking losing his pension and
his retirement i don't believe he ever
thought that he would be facing years in
prison and it should not we're gonna
stay on this everyone get uh go back go
to bat for lieutenant colonel schiller
no donation is too small
pipehitterfoundation.org thanks so much
guys i'll talk to you again soon
thank you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now